the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of Thrones update
video I'm sure some of you may have seen
the headlines by now but if you haven't
I have some good news and I have some
bad news as you all know HBO has been
working on several news shows that are
based on a song of ice and fire and fire
and blood after the success of Game of
Thrones HBO is hoping they can ride that
wave by releasing other shows that take
place within George RR Martin's universe
well the first show that was given the
greenlight was said to be set roughly
5000 years ago during the Age of Heroes
not only were we gonna see the Starks in
this show but we were also gonna see the
true origin of the White Walkers well it
does not look like we're gonna be
getting this anytime soon the series
known as the long night and or also
known as Blood Moon has been cancelled
by HBO Time magazine said another one
bites the dust
HBO scrapp's Game of Thrones prequel set
during the long night in the wake of the
news that Game of Thrones showrunners
David Benioff and DB Weiss are stepping
away from the Star Wars trilogy they had
planned to develop for Lucasfilm HBO has
reportedly cancelled one of its highly
anticipated game of Thrones prequels
according to Entertainment Weekly the
network has scrapped Jane Goldman's Game
of Thrones successor show a series that
was set to take place thousands of years
before the rise of Daenerys Targaryen
and chronicled Westeros is descent from
the Age of Heroes into the long night
Naomi Watts was slated to star in the
prequel which shot a full pilot episode
directed by SJ Clarkson in Northern
Ireland earlier this year a Song of Ice
and Fire author george RR martin
co-created the project with goldman now
i have yet to see HBO release a
statement about why they cancelled the
show
they had already filmed the first
episode so I can only assume the
executives at HBO were not happy with it
I'm actually not surprised because this
same thing happened when Dan and Dave
handed in the first episode for Game of
Thrones it was very obvious they did not
know what they were doing so they had to
rewrite a lot of the scenes fire and
hire new actors then obviously reshoot
most of the scenes as well
obviously that second version became the
first episode of Game of Thrones which
we know today now what does surprise me
is HBO not giving the new show a second
chance this is just speculation but
maybe the reaction to season 8 had
something to do with it a lot of us were
very upset with how the show ended but
one thing we were specifically not happy
with us how the White Walkers story
ended I mean they essentially gave us no
answers at all
and this new show set during the long
night would be very close to repeating
the White Walkers story with maybe some
new details here and error but I know
just by reading the comments on my own
videos most of you were not interested
in getting another show about the White
Walkers especially after how Dan and
Dave handled their story so maybe they
are taking that into consideration but
honestly who knows right now not to
mention there is almost no source
material for that time period you got to
look at it like this dan and Dave had
over 5,000 pages of source material to
adapt the Song of Ice and Fire into Game
of Thrones and even with that much
source material they still butcher the
story for a lot of the fans so given the
fact that there is absolutely no source
material for the Age of Heroes in the
long night maybe that had something to
do with it as well even though they knew
that going into it hopefully they will
release a statement soon although I
doubt they would ever admit the backlash
had anything to do with them cancelling
that particular show anyways now let's
get into the good news it does look like
there is a very good chance we will
still be getting another new show after
all
according to Entertainment Weekly HBO
gives Game of Thrones Targaryen prequel
a full series order HBO announced
Tuesday that it's Game of Thrones
prequel project about the Targaryen
Civil War has officially received a full
series order for 10 episodes the spot-on
title house of the Dragon also announced
emmy-winning Game of Thrones director
Miguel support snake will serve as Co
showrunner and direct the pilot support
snake directed acclaimed episodes such
as battle of the bastards hardhome and
the long night the announcement came
just hours after the news Burke that the
network's first game of Thrones prequel
project from showrunner Jane Goldman
starring Naomi Watts was not moving
forward the new prequel was co-created
by author George are Martin and Ryan
Condal who will also be a showrunner on
the series a poster was also released
with the tagline fire will reign the
Game of Thrones universe is so rich with
stories
Kaycee boys president HBO programming we
look forward to exploring the origins of
House Targaryen in the earlier days of
Westeros along with miguel ryan and
george house of the dragon is based on
martin's 2019 book fire and blood
a history of House Targaryen that spans
roughly a hundred and fifty years Game
of Thrones writer producer Bryan cogman
originally developed the project at the
network like the other prequel the story
takes place long before the events in
Game of Thrones but not nearly as far
back as the Goldman project a couple
hundred years before Ned Stark and
Daenerys Targaryen give or take so
Westeros will look different than it is
in Game of Thrones but not too
dramatically different based on what
Martin has written about the era house
of the dragon also takes place during a
time in Westeros that has plenty of
dramatic established history penned by
Martin to serve as a backbone for the
story whereas the pilot had only some
vague references to build on the events
in the new series will eventually lead
up to the dance of the Dragons a massive
civil war in the Seven Kingdoms held
between two rival branches of House
Targaryen the prequel order is the
latest in a dramatic succession a game
of Thrones related news over the last 24
hours on Monday Lucasfilm announced that
Game of Thrones share winners David
Benioff and Dan Weiss who often not to
be involved in the prequels are stepping
away from their planned Star Wars
trilogy then the Goldman project which
shot a full pilot in Northern Ireland
this summer was scrapped
now HBO's other prequel has left from
development into an official series
order the news was announced at Warner
media's presentation to investors on
Tuesday focused on the launch of its
2020 streaming service HBO max now this
news obviously has me very excited
because HBO has decided to skip a few
steps by immediately ordering a full
season of episodes for this House
Targaryen series I'm also excited to
learn that they are bringing back Miguel
supports Nick who is well known for
directing some a game of Thrones best
episodes it does look like HBO is
bringing out the big guns for House of
the Dragon since george RR martin did
just release fire in blood it does make
more sense for them to move forward with
this show since they do have some source
material for this time period
unlike the series about the long night
I'm sure we will be finding out a lot
more details within the coming days
anyways let me know your thoughts about
all these recent developments
Are you disappointed the long night
series was
cancelled and are you excited for the
house of the Dragon I would love to see
what you have to say thank you all for
stopping by to watch the update video I
appreciate everyone for continuing to
support the channel I hope you all have
a great day I will see you soon bye